uh okay it has now been confirmed that
climate denial is going to be the
official position of the Donald
administration there are few issues that
are bigger than climate change currently
facing not only Americans but the world
it's an environmental issue the national
security issue it's an economic issue
it's a health issue we knew it wasn't
looking great for the Donald
administration when we found out he was
going to put climate science denier
Myron Ebel in charge of the EPA
transition that was bad enough but it's
gotten even worse if you can imagine
that incoming White House chief of staff
rents Priebus said on Fox News that the
default position the main position the
primary position of the Donald
administration on humans causing climate
change will be that it is mostly bogus
here's a quote from rinse previous on
Fox News Sunday number two as far as
this issue on climate change the only
thing he was saying after being asked a
few questions about it is look he'll
have an open mind about it but he has
his default position which most of it is
a bunch of bunk but he'll have an open
mind and listen to people I think that's
what he's saying you can't really have
an open mind on climate science if your
default position is that in spite of
ninety-eight percent of scientists
agreeing on what the position is taking
the position that those ninety eight
percent of scientists are wrong that's
not exactly the definition of an open
mind Pat which should really confuse us
because the definition of a blind trust
according to Donald Trump clearly is not
a blind trust at all and we know that
scientists are as confident as humans
that the primary cause of climate change
is human activities on earth there is
sure of the impact that humans are
having on climate as we are about the
impact that smoking cigarettes has on
health how would we react Pat if someone
was a smoking science denier and Donald
Trump has talked a lot about
deregulating the EPA too and I mean the
issue here is that a lot of these things
are time sensitive I mean we've gone on
a course that we can't really reverse
when it comes to climate change and for
28 years down the road we certainly
won't be
too no doubt about it this is not the
type of thing where we should be be
playing politics with and that's exactly
what it is when you choose to take the
two percent of the one percent of the
0.3% opinion and make it as rinse
previous said the default position of
your administration it's ironic in some
way that while Trump slams China for
everything including stuff that they're
not doing that China could actually be
one of the most important forces in
fighting climate change Trump wants to
go to war with them economic war trade
war as we've talked about and the damage
may be more as Pat is talking about not
only to the future of the US but also to
the credibility of the US during the
next four or eight years because this is
the consensus period and to think that
you have an incoming administration in
the United States you are the supposedly
der of the free world although
increasingly the consensus is it's not
going to be Trump it's going to be
ongola Merkel the German Chancellor once
Trump is sworn in taking the position
that my default is with the 0.3% of
climate scientists sort of an odd
position to take is your default
position on this issue and it's an up
absolute and utter disaster this is not
one of those areas where there is
overlap between the Bernie Sanders
position and the Donald Trump position
and progressives have their work cut out
for them for the next 48 years to stop
essentially a science denying madman on
the loose deregulating in a way that
will irreversibly damaged the only
planet we currently have let's take a
break join the discussion on reddit at
david pakman.com slash re d di t gamefly
is sort of like netflix for video games
they have over 8,000 new and classic
games for xbox one xbox 360 ps4 ps3 wii
and a bunch of other platforms and you
can play as many games as you want for
one monthly fee and if you find some
games you want to keep you can buy them
for a low used price there's never any
due dates or late fees and our audience
can get a free 30-day trial at gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s
the games are shipped directly to you
with return envelopes included there's
no contracts and you can rent games
through the mobile app get the free
30-day trial for the david pakman show
audience and support our show by going
to gamefly offer.com slash TDP s